Red Dead Redemption - is coming to game
Pass Castlevania has been confirmed for
season four and the battlefield 5
roadmap has one more big update I'm
Persia and you've made it to your safe
state for Thursday April 23rd GameSpot's
2018 game of the year Red Dead
Redemption - is coming to Xbox ones game
pass on May 7th Red Dead 2 is already
available for pre download and will also
include Red Dead online but as one great
game joins the service we'll have to say
goodbye to another Grand Theft Auto 5
will be leaving game past the same day
which gives you just two more weeks to
play it what are your favorite game past
titles for me personally it's Orion
will-o'-the-wisps season 4 of
Castlevania has been confirmed in the
most hilarious of ways season 3 was even
more popular than season 2 and fans have
been anxiously waiting for more news on
it
creator Warren Ellis confirmed a new
season in a blog post he said so we're
on for season 4 we don't expect too much
of a kovat related delay but if that one
guy who keeps attacking me on IG to
demand season 4 now
could f off I'd really appreciate it
there is no official release date yet
but rest assured it's on the way what do
you want to see for the new season and
while we're on the topic of Netflix the
first 12 episodes of Pokemon journeys is
coming to the platform on June 12 and
the theme song is by walk off the earth
they sing that cool cover of somebody
that I used to know the show well as
you'd expect follow Ash and Pikachu on
their adventures in the Pokemon world
and incorporate some elements from
soreness shields since the trailer shows
score bunny and Giganta max Snorlax I'm
excited to see all the Pokemon that they
meet along the way
but if you don't see your favorite
Pokemon in the first 12 episodes then
don't worry because they're releasing
new episodes quarterly which Pokemon are
you looking forward to the most I'm
hoping for some sylveon the source code
for Team Fortress and a counterstrike
global Offensive was leaked yesterday
but since our last save state valve has
told us it is not worried valve confirm
the legitimacy of the leak but
apparently the code was from a 2018
buildup the game's therefore no risk of
the game being messed with in 2020 valve
has not announced whether it intends to
pursue legal action against the leaker
or whether this instance will influence
its real
ship with the source engine modding
community going forward what are your
favorite source mods any Garry's Mod
fans out there battlefield 5 senior
producer announcement Andy a blog post
that won a big update is coming to the
large-scale multiplayer shooter this
summer this is likely the last major
update plant for the game it will add
new content weapons and game tweaks but
there are no mentions of new Maps one
more update may sound like an end point
but MacArthur also mentioned they'll be
engaging with the fans even more by
hosting weekly offense to play with the
community and revisit throwback
battlefield games the timing makes sense
considering EA has already announced a
next-gen battlefield and is expecting to
launch it before March 2020 what are you
looking to see out of the next
battlefield and that is a wrap on
today's stories you can follow me on
twitter at persia underscore XO and make
sure you reach your savestate every day
here on GameSpot
[Music]